hôm nay, bán thường vụ đang bị cố gọi đã thông nhất với tờ trình và thông qua quyết định thành lập bộ phận nghiên cứu trên đề chực thuật đang bị cố gọi.
Với thành lập bộ phận nghiên cứu trên đề chực thuật đang bị cố gọi.
Lạc cần thiết, nhằm cụ thể ngoái trụ trên của bộ chiến chỉ, bán bị thơ.
Tạo kế chế tập hợp phát vi đổi mũ cán bộ thuật dạc bộ chiến chỉ, bán bị thơ quyết định điều đầu.
Vân công bộ chiến tham dàng nghiên cứu trên đề.
Thăng cường năng lực nghiên cứu, tổng kế thực tiến, tư vấn chuyên sâu đối với các vấn đề lớn mới, có đã lĩnh vật thu vụ sự lãnh đạo chỉ đạo của đàn bị cố gọi.
Bán thử vụ đang bị cố gọi.
Thương trực đang bị cố gọi.
Và đồng chỉ bị thơ đang bị cố gọi.
Bộ phận có chức năng tham yêu, tư vấn vụ bán thử vụ đang bị cố gọi.
Thương trực đang bị cố gọi.
Đồng chỉ bị thơ đang bị cố gọi.
Chúng tìc của gọi trong lãnh đạo chỉ đạo thực hiện giận vụ của đàn bị cố gọi.
Và những dạm vụ liên quan đến đổi mới tổ chức, phạt động của cố gọi theo phần công.
Chiu sự lãnh đạo chỉ đạo thực tiếp của bán thử vụ đang bị cố gọi.
Thương trực đang bị cố gọi.
Và đồng chỉ bị thưa đang bị cố gọi.
Bây nhiên vụ, bộ phận tạm chung nghiên cứu, tổng kế thực tiến,
tham yêu về đổi mới tổ chức và hạt động của cố gọi.
Y bán thử vụ cố gọi.
Các cơ quan của cố gọi.
Mình cao chất lợ lợ pháp, giám sát tử cao.
Cuy định các bán đề quan sọng của đơn nước.
Tổ chức và hạt động rất nguyên tiếp súc của chi giám sát vẹt dạy quyết kiến nghị của
của chi và nhân dân.
Chuyền lợi số cơ sở rữ liệu ứng dụng chỉ tựa nhận tạo.
Hồi nhập quốc tế, lưỡng ngoại nghị viện tham gia y kến phản biệt.
Góp ý đổi với các đẻ án chương trình kế hoạc.
Bá cáo lớn thuật phản vi lãnh đạo chỉ đạo của đàn bị cố gọi.
Khi được phân công và thực hiện các nhập vụ khác, cho các có thần quyền rào.
Thại hồi nghị.
Y bán thực vụ của hội của thần nhất với tự trình và thông quan nghĩ quyết thành lập cuộc chuyển
đổi số thuật phản phòng của hội.
Theo tự trình, viết thành lập này phù hợp với yêu cầu thực hiện lột phá về qua
công nghệ đổi mấy sáng tạo và chuyển đổi số.
Nát ứng yêu cầu xây dựng của hội số, quan chỉ dưới liệu ứng dụng chỉ tựa nhận tạo.
Bà đảm hạt tân số, mẹn tạo số, ăn tọn thu tín.
Cung cắt thông tin, 1 mẹ hạt động của khu hội trên môi trường số.
Đồng thời, tạo đồng mối chuyên trách hó đủ thầm quyền, năng lực, điều kiện tổ chức để thảm ưu,
quan lý, sinh khai thông nhất nhận vụ chuyển đổi số trong hệ thống các thương quan của khu hội.